You know, it says, "Out of Workshop" for a reason.
I'm so sorry to bother you, boss, but something has come up,...
...and it's kind of a big deal.
What is it?
Have you ever heard of the World Cup?
Well, they moved it to the holidays.
Wait.
The actual World Cup to the holiday season?
Are you kidding me?
Sir, I know...
You're telling me that they went ahead...
...and moved the biggest sporting event on the planet...
...right into the middle of my holiday season?
Yeah.
It's a big deal.
There's Messi and Ronaldo.
Yeah, but that's my time to shine.
I mean, that guy has got like 300 million followers.
How am I supposed to compete with that?
I think it's like 400 million.
400 million!
Okay, great.
You know what?
Get Blitzen on the phone.
I got to get on the next flight up there.
We got work to do.
Well, I...
Oh, I gotta go, I gotta go.
You know what? I got a turkey sandwich coming, you can have it.